Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
Come on! Who wants to make
a lot of dough?!
Whoa!
When 10,000 people
are doing the same thing,
I don't want to be
the 10,001st.
Sharks, these bandits cause
thousands of dollars
in damages a day.
♪♪
To wear the crown
is a huge responsibility.
What?!
We need help.
This is like kryptonite
to me.
Guys,
your marketing sucks.
Things aren't always
as they look.
What?!
Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait.
Wait a minute!
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a quick and affordable
version of a favorite meal.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks!
I make a lot of dough!
Pasta dough, baby!
What?!
I'm Brandon Fay,
and I'm seeking $150,000,
10% equity of my company.
Sharks, when you want
to go eat Italian,
first thing
comes to your mind ‐‐
"Oh, boy.
I gotta go to a restaurant.
Even with a reservation,
I'm gonna wait a while."
Then, the pasta's expensive,
and then by the time the pasta
finally comes, it's cold.
It's not even fresh pasta!
And that's why I started
my company, Pasta by Hudson.
We're a fast‐casual,
quick‐service, fresh pasta bar
located in the heart
of New York City!
So, you look at the menu.
Step 1 ‐‐ pick a pasta shape,
like campanelle little bells
or bucatini.
[ Italian accent ]
Long‐a pasta, like‐a spaghetti.
[ Normal voice ]
We even have veggie pasta
if you don't want carbs.
Step 2 ‐‐ pick a sauce!
We have a carbonara.
Ridiculously decadent,
creamy sauce
with a fried egg
sitting right on top,
smoked applewood bacon.
Or how about try
our popular alla vodka?
It's a sweet blend
of our hand‐crushed tomato sauce
and Alfredo.
Oh, there's more!
Step 3 ‐‐
grab an extra if you want,
everything from shrimp
to garlic toast,
burrata creamy mozzarella.
We've got our famous signature
cheesy stuffed meatball.
You can keep it simple,
you can mix it up.
You can eat it now,
you can eat it later.
Come on! Who wants to make
a lot of dough?!
Yeah!
Whoa!
Now, in front of you, you got
a lot of delicious pasta.
Let me tell you something ‐‐
if you cook with love,
people can tell.
They know right away.
Ohh!
Mmm.
That is so good.
So, allow me, please.
Excellent.
Corcoran: This is fabulous.
Pomodoro ‐‐ great.
What's this here?
Cuban:
Yeah. Gemelli pomodoro.
Oh, gosh.
Mmm!
Unh!
Oh, wow. The meatball.
Corcoran: My God.
Let me tell you ‐‐ this is
the best meatball I've ever had.
Why don't you tell us
about you,
how you started this business,
and what you were doing before?
Well, first of all,
I'm the son
of two New York City
police officers.
My parents were actually
Bridge and Tunnel officers.
Really?
My dad was a sergeant.
But [Smooches] he's since gone,
but we love him and miss him
every day of my life.
Are you
an Italian extract?
You don't look Italian
at all.
I'm Jewish and Irish!
‐Nice!
‐Come on.
‐Irish?
They make
the best Italian food.
Make the best Italian food.
Help me visualize
your operation.
Is it a store?
Is it a truck?
So, we actually have
a picture.
I can show you
what it looks like.
Good.
We've got 390 square feet.
It's one store?
It's one store right now.
Where is that located?
We're located
in Columbus Circle.
We're in the eighth‐busiest
transit hub in New York City.
24 million people a year
go through there.
When I walk up here for lunch,
what am I spending?
So, your pomodoro starts
at $8.95.
Then the rest of the dishes,
about $12 to $13.
Are you a chef? How did you
come up with this idea?
So, no training experience.
I ran
one of the busiest restaurants,
not only in New York City,
but in pretty much
the United States.
You were the manager
of the restaurant?
I was managing director,
130 employees.
And then when you work in
a restaurant your
whole entire life ‐‐
I'm almost 25 years
in the industry ‐‐
you pick up a few things.
So, what are
your sales to date?
Year to date,
we're at about $590,000.
And your overhead
is what?
$55,000 a month.
Is that
your business model,
to continue opening
within food courts,
where the business
tends to come to you
because there's
so many people going by?
You hit the nail
on the head.
So, my business plan
is to open up
in very high‐volume,
high‐foot‐traffic areas.
Are you profitable now?
By the end of the year,
we'll probably break even
on the first year.
By next year, I predict
that I'll at least do ‐‐
I'll do 1.2, 1.3.
Is this gonna be expansion
of just you opening locations
or franchise or both?
I see us making sure
we build a foundation ‐‐
really solid, right?
And yes, we do franchising ‐‐
probably a little bit too early,
but that's something
we can always talk about.
What's it cost you
to open one?
So, this one was 350,
but we learned a lot,
and when I was looking
at possibly doing,
like, a smaller kiosk, that one
would have been, like, 200.
Everything gets more efficient.
So, 350
to get the doors open.
Brandon...
Yes, sir?
...I think
it's a genius idea,
but I have
a personal issue
on why this may be
a challenge for me.
I have horrible acid reflux.
Horrible.
So, you know,
I can't have onions,
I can't have tomato base.
This is like kryptonite
to me,
even though
it was delicious.
So, unfortunately, I'm out.
Totally understand.
Cuban: Do you guys do
delivery at all
or have an app
where people can pick?
The blend of my business right
now is actually half of that ‐‐
almost half is delivery.
That's good, though, right?
It is good.
What we're learning is, they do
take a big commission, right?
Yeah, they take
20, 25%, yeah.
Yeah.
Does that make sense
for you?
I am so thankful for
the business they've given me
because it's huge.
It opens you up to
a larger market a mile away,
people that have never
even known I'm there.
It's about where am I
going in the future and how
big I'm gonna grow this.
Well, and let's talk about
future, right?
Because, really, your biggest
future is delivery‐only.
Like, if I knew that you had
spaghetti squash on there,
this size with that sauce,
and it was 250 calories,
I'm ordering every night.
And they've got
the place ‐‐
you know, CloudKitchen
and the places like that,
where you just have the kitchen,
they do the rest.
I mean, would you be open to
doing just a CloudKitchen?
Satellite kitchens.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
'Cause then you have
more of a market going
in other directions.
You're not there ‐‐
much lower rent
because those places
aren't storefronts.
And you can go to more cities
more often, quicker.
Correct.
Brandon,
the food's spectacular.
It's a break‐even business.
It's not franchisable yet.
You'd have to be making 15%
pre‐tax to franchise.
You're a ways off for that.
Too early for me.
I'm out.
Alright. By the way,
you're more than welcome
to come back in if you want.
Corcoran: [ Laughs ]
I would love it,
'cause you're Mr. Wonderful.
Obviously,
your food is fabulous.
That meatball ‐‐
I wasn't just saying ‐‐
it's the best meatball
I've ever eaten.
The best meatball
I've ever eaten ‐‐ by far, okay?
So I want that recipe.
Done.
Okay.
What does it cost you
to make one meatball?
About 45 cents.
And what do you
sell them for?
$4.95.
Wow.
Do they freeze well?
Oh, yes. I froze them
and shipped them here.
Youse two can partner
together...
It would be great...
...and we could crush this.
I have a deal for you.
Listen to this.
We could crush this.
Hey, be quiet a minute.
I have a deal for you.
Alright, listen,
if Mark will do it,
I'd go in with Mark.
While they're going in
with Mark,
let me suggest
what I'll do.
Yes, please.
Okay? Alright.
Mark.
I'll give you the $150,000
for 50%.
Say that number again.
I couldn't hear you.
I'll give you $150,000
for 50%
of your meatball business
if you'll get it online.
You can make a fortune.
[ Laughing ]
Just online meatballs?
That's an amazing offer.
The fact that you even
gave me an offer ‐‐ believe
me, that's wonderful.
Would you mind if I hear
what Lori and Mark have to say?
I don't mind at all.
Help yourself.
And I'm considering that.
I only like the meatballs.
I'm considering everything
because ‐‐
Are you interested
in going in together?
Cuban: I want 20%.
Well, Mark wants 20%,
which means,
what is that
going to be left for me?
Right?
So, I'm gonna ‐‐
[ Italian accent ]
A meatball.
Mark, is that 20%
10, 10?
No. I need to get to 20.
No, he doesn't want that.
He wants 20% himself.
What does that
leave for me?
Well, let me ask you
something ‐‐ if, hypothetical,
if I gave you both 15,
and you know I know operations,
you know I know food,
and I'm gonna crush it,
are you gonna help me
blow this thing up?
Yeah, look, I'm not investing
to not help it grow.
Of course.
Right?
I'll give you the $150,000,
I want 20%,
and I have no problem
partnering with Lori.
The only thing
that I require
is that we seriously consider
the CloudKitchens,
'cause that allows us to go into
as many markets as you want.
If Lori wants to come in
and negotiate something
on top of that,
I'm kosher with that.
Well, I liked your $150,000,
15 and 15.
Why wouldn't you
do that, Mark?
What do you mean?
Did you hear that?
Because that's actually
a very good offer to us.
Not to me.
Oh, come on. 5%?
Seriously.
Just take 10%, then,
Lori.
But we ‐‐ 10%.
How much of my money are you
offering him for the 10%?
Okay, Brandon,
here's what we're gonna do.
I'm gonna put in 100K,
Lori's gonna put up 50K.
We're gonna take 30%.
I'll keep 20 of it,
she'll keep 10.
Do we have a deal?
Alright, I'll do it.
Okay. Deal.
Corcoran: Wait a minute!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
You didn't agree to it.
Do you agree to it?
Greiner: Done.
I ‐‐ Come on!
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, baby! Yeah!
[ Laughs ]
Yeah!
Now I'm gonna tell you
something, Brandon ‐‐
you made a mistake here.
You had another deal
on the table,
and you never even
entertained it.
And, listen, I'm
unbelievably grateful that
you even made an offer,
but I know that I
got a great team here,
I know I'm gonna crush it.
Go make us some money.
No more sucking up.
I'm gonna start cooking!
Go cook.
Whoo! Whoo!
Yes! Whoo!
Oh, yeah! Here we go!
Feeling awesome!
Are you kidding me?
Dreams come true,
especially in the Shark Tank.
Worked my entire life, so hard,
and I'm sitting here
partnering up with two of
the best people in the business.
There's no doubt we're gonna
take the business from here
and just explode it and just do
amazing things with it.
How about you guys give me an
option on the meatball business?
What's the big deal?
It's added revenue
for the whole business.
No, 'cause we want
that meatball business.
We trust your judgment,
Barb.
You ‐‐ [ Exhales sharply ]
Whatever.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a fashionable solution
to a common problem for babies.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Lily.
And I'm Linsey.
Both: And we're from Goumi.
We're seeking
$1 million....
Oh!
Whoo!
...for 8% equity
in our company.
Holy...
Sharks, we're obsessed
with the power of small.
Babies are amazing miracles,
but as newborns,
they tend to have limited
motor control in their hands,
and that's why many
scratch their faces.
Also, they tend to lose a lot
of heat in their extremities,
heat that they're gonna need
to thrive,
all while growing
at a rapid pace.
This is why mittens
and booties and pajamas
are on
every baby checklist.
But let's face it ‐‐ the current
products on the market
just aren't well‐designed.
I mean, how many parents have
dealt with the frustration
of losing that tiny mitten
or that tiny sock
because they
just don't stay on?
We have solved this problem one
tiny hand and foot at a time.
[ Chuckles ]
Goumi is a thoughtfully
designed line
of essential baby products
that are functional,
comfortable, breathable,
and sustainable,
as well as beautiful.
Our flagship product,
Goumi mitts, is unique
because they actually stay on
and protect the baby.
We do this with our
signature two‐part closure.
Clever.
Our Goumi boots
feature the two‐part
closure system, as well,
using elastic to tighten
and Velcro to secure.
So these boots
actually do stay on.
Our patented Goumi Jamms
go from gown to sleep sock
in one snap.
Sharks, who's ready to join us
unleash the power of small?
[ Chuckles ]
We've given you
two different types.
One is a "Welcome home" set
for babies
that are going to be
coming home from the hospital.
Really cool packaging.
‐Thank you.
‐Smart. Super smart.
‐It's amazing how common sense
just has, you know,
the most amazing impact.
Oh, you have no idea
how many nurses
have come to us in all
these NICU conferences
that we've gone to, said,
"I had this idea years ago."
[ Chuckles ]
I have a 3‐year‐old,
but when she came home,
for probably about
the first six months,
we were wondering why
she had all these scratches
on her ankle.
We just didn't think that
her toenails were cutting her.
People think, "Oh, sure,
we'll just buy a nail‐cutter,
and we'll trim them," and
you're sleep‐deprived, right?
You don't want to cut them
'cause they're just so small.
It's hard to trim
those little nails.
Correct. Correct.
What's your background?
Because I'm from Portland,
it just kind of made sense
that I work for Nike,
right?
And so that's what I did
for the first seven years
of my career.
Still stayed
in apparel and footwear.
Worked for Adidas,
and then worked at HP
to learn about digital analytics
and research.
My background
is I used to sell ‐‐
well, I currently
sell zippers, still,
and buttons
to the apparel industry,
so I'm kind of on the supplier
side of the equation.
Is that how y'all met?
No, no.
We met
at a Chinese preschool
that we sent
our little bon‐bons to,
'cause they were gonna be
fluent in Chinese together.
And we live in China
currently.
‐Live in China?
‐You're in China now?
Yes.
She flew here from Xiamen.
So, what are you
selling them for,
and what does it cost you
to make them?
So, the whole bundle
retails for $102.
$102?
O'Leary:
And it costs to make...?
$14.
What?!
It's only $14 to make it?
So, landed...
Landed duty ‐‐
probably $17, $18.
It helps to have connections
in China.
[ Both laugh ]
Why do you find $102
is your sweet spot?
Did you test it at a lower price
and then a higher price?
We did. We did.
I mean, we've been in
business for eight years.
This year,
we're gonna sell ‐‐
we're on track to sell
our millionth unit.
Millionth unit?
1 millionth unit.
O'Leary: Okay, break down
the numbers for me.
How much for the booties?
$2.20, retail $18.
Okay.
Mittens ‐‐ retail, $24.
Yeah.
Cost to make,
including packaging, $4.50.
Are you selling this
all direct‐to‐consumer?
We've been around
for eight years,
so in the beginning,
we were selling to Gen X moms.
So, we were distributing
at baby boutiques,
as well as Amazon,
as well as brick‐and‐mortar
and specialty.
Whereas now,
it's really shifted
to a lot more
direct‐to‐consumer.
So, total sales?
Year to date.
Total sales ‐‐
5.5 ‐‐ $5.2 million.
O'Leary: What about this year?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Total sales lifetime?
Lifetime. 5.2.
5.2. Okay.
John: But one second.
I'm astonished
they're so low.
So, back in the day,
it was a really heavy
wholesale business.
O'Leary: What is this year
gonna be, total sales?
2 1/2.
What are you gonna make
on it?
About 15% profitability.
We've been profitable
since year 1.
You've put this ‐‐
$1 million for 8%.
That imbues
a $12.5 million valuation.
That's a little rich.
That's a lot rich.
It's a little rich.
However, we did
our first fundraising round
back in early 2018.
We were at $1 million
in sales.
We had a post money
at $5 million valuation then.
Yeah, but you've
only doubled sales.
There's a sucker born
every minute.
I bet those suckers are
scratching their face.
But we're growing.
We have
a clear line of sight
for $5 million business
next year.
Why aren't sales more?
It's a wholesale business,
largely.
That's where we came from.
And so, now, I would say,
in the last 18 months or so,
we've really got
into direct,
and we're seeing
some very, very good numbers.
And what percentage
of your sales are direct sales?
Oh, direct now?
Probably around 15% to 20%.
That's a good start.
Yeah.
That's the disconnect.
You're in distribution.
Why not more?
I mean,
because how are ‐‐
Is it your point of sale
not working?
Is it the display
No. That's a great question,
Mark.
So, therein lies, I think,
a challenge for being small.
You know, it's like,
they come back and say,
"Well, we need
more assortment.
We need more sizes.
We need more products."
Every client says that.
They don't mean it.
About everything.
Yeah. And we get that
a lot.
Greiner: Well,
but if you have orders,
I'm wondering
if the price point for ‐‐
It's really high.
Because if you have a baby
of that age,
you probably need at least two,
three, or four pair of each.
Correct.
So, now you're into
over $100
just for the booties
and the mittens.
Where did you do the testing
of this price?
We did it essentially
just online.
Okay.
What you see
on the display here
is really what's at
brick‐and‐mortar.
Okay.
That's à la carte.
Cuban: So, that's
your in‐store display.
Correct.
Yeah, so,
that's the problem, right?
Because there's
no 1‐inch description.
There's nothing
that really says
"Your kids are
gonna scratch themselves
if you don't use this,"
right?
Mm‐hmm.
That's the disconnect,
and I think
you have to solve that.
This hasn't gone
into store yet.
This is just a prototype.
Oh, so, what's in the store?
Just that?
Yeah, so, in store
and baby boutiques,
it's our trees,
which can hold 48 units.
That's even worse.
That's even worse, guys.
We're under‐telling
our story.
No, there's
no story at all.
You're not telling
a story at all.
Guys, the net of it is,
your marketing sucks.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but Mark is critical
of how Lily and Linsey
are marketing their high‐end
baby apparel company, Goumi.
That's why
we need the money.
That's fixable.
That's absolutely fixable.
But it's not. You're
asking us to give you
$1 million to fix that.
That's why we're here.
We need help in that department.
But at a $12.5 million
valuation,
we're paying you
to hire us.
Guys, that's not gonna work
for me.
For those reasons, I'm out.
Thank you.
So, I'm trying
to figure out,
how are you getting
to that valuation?
I'm choking
on the valuation.
Is it the need
for that amount of capital?
Is it you just think
you're gonna be that good?
'Cause usually,
a business figures itself out
in seven years.
The valuation largely came
from the fact
that we were able to raise
that valuation before.
The other thing is,
moving from a wholesale
to a direct business ‐‐
huge for us.
We've gotten customer
acquisition numbers
now down to $16,
sometimes $8.
And we're moving ‐‐
historically, it went
from mitts and boots business
to now much more of a gifting
and higher‐priced
product business.
Those are the two
main reasons.
You've been in business
for eight years,
and you have $5.2 million?
I have another sock business ‐‐
Grace & Lace ‐‐
and they were in business
for five years
and they have $15 million.
That's a sizable difference.
I believe that the problem
you have that they don't have
is they have
70% returning customers.
You're in
the new baby business,
so it's very, very expensive
for you
to constantly start
and find new customers,
and I believe that's why
you're only doing 15% online.
I think it's gonna be
very, very hard,
and I think
it's grossly overpriced.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Thanks.
I will say ‐‐ I think that you
have a great‐quality product.
It's really quite beautiful.
It's very premium and high‐end.
There's a market for that.
I personally, though,
have spent my career
creating great‐quality product
but trying hard to make it
at an affordable price
so that my products
could be enjoyed by all.
While I love what you're doing,
it's not the right model for me.
Sorry. I'm out.
Yeah, I think you're trying
to tell two stories, right?
A luxury...
Mm‐hmm.
...and then solution, and
solution is the most important.
I don't want to downplay
the great job
that you've already done.
The product's excellent.
But the valuation
is just...crazy.
Okay, so let's talk about
a proper valuation
at what you think is fair.
O'Leary: Well, that's what
I've been trying to do
since you started your pitch.
It's just ‐‐
John: You know what?
It ‐‐ I can't hurt to ask.
$1 million for...
30%.
Cuban: Hello.
Mm.
O'Leary: That's about right.
That's a very big leap.
That's about
what it's worth right now.
I should be in this space
because I already own
the wedding space.
Mm‐hmm.
It's a perfect connection.
What happens
when people get married?
They have babies.
And then they send
Lovepop cards to them
and then they send...
Wicked Good Cupcakes as gifts
and all that stuff.
That's what we do.
But this valuation
is a choker.
The way I'd structure this deal
is I'd say to you,
okay, look, you're gonna need
money for inventory
because you're in
the retail business.
I'll give you the million
dollars in a line of credit.
9%.
You can draw it down
as you need it,
but I want 10% of the company
for doing that.
You can always counter
to either of these two offers.
Yes. Yes.
Mm‐hmm.
I was thinking
of doing so.
I really, really appreciate
both of your guys' experience,
and I think you could do
a lot for our business.
However, I'm not sure
if a line of credit
is what we need.
Oh, yeah?
Per se.
[ Chuckling ]
You're gonna need it.
Well ‐‐ And, again, you're more
of the expert than we are.
Yes, I am.
Daymond, would you consider
15% for a million?
No.
It's too rich a valuation.
You really came in
with a big valuation.
And it was using
off of the rubric
that we worked off before.
O'Leary: Look, Sharks aren't
like your other investors.
They don't bring what we bring.
‐It's true.
This is
a whole different ballgame.
Can you help me understand
your deal, again?
It's very simple.
You need a line of credit.
You don't know it yet,
but you're gonna need it.
We have one. We have one
for a quarter of a million now.
Ooh!
At 5%.
‐Oh!
‐That's why they don't need it.
A quarter of a million?
That's nothing.
Is it drawn down?
It's not at all touched.
‐Good for you.
‐Ooh!
If you want to blow this up,
you're gonna have to
carry inventory
for 60 to 90 days in retail.
I agree, and my manufacturer,
my factory's already ready
to give us
longer terms than 60.
Ooh!
What happens when this gets
to Lace & Grace at 15 mil?
Correct.
You're gonna need
$3 million...
That's true.
...in retail.
I don't think either of
these offers are gonna change.
It's time to decide.
♪♪
[ Conversing in Chinese ]
Okay.
I think, Mr. Wonderful,
you've got a deal.
[ Laughter ]
‐Oh!
‐Surprise.
‐Congrats.
‐That's a bad deal.
Thank you.
Let's go make some money.
Let's make some money.
Thank you.
Congratulations, guys.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Congratulations, you guys.
‐You guys are awesome.
♪♪
Yeo: Do not give up
on your dream.
Get it out there,
get it out.
Do not be afraid
because you're small.
I'm so proud of you.
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Narrator: Last season,
Barbara Corcoran made a deal
with brothers
Bryan and Caleb Lewis
for their gourmet
Belgian waffle business
Press Waffle Co.
This is sick.
It's sick in a good way.
Let's see
how they're doing now.
A gourmet Belgian waffle is
change‐your‐life kind of good.
It is an authentic
Liege‐style recipe
with clusters
of Belgian pearl sugar,
giving it a caramel crust
and a candy coating.
Mmm.
I want one right now.
[ Chuckles ]
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had done $450,000 in sales.
Since we made a deal
with Barbara,
we've done $1.3 million
in sales.
Today, we're here
in Oklahoma City
for the grand opening
of our fourth location
and our first
outside of Texas.
We are so excited to have
Barbara here today with us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Corcoran: I came here
to share the success,
but what I never expected
was the energy in this room
and how many people
are cheering for these guys.
This is a business that is gonna
go as high and as crazy
as these guys dreamt it would.
And last,
but certainly not least,
I want you guys to meet our
very first franchise partners,
who are gonna be opening
their very own store
in just a few short weeks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What's great about
the franchise model is,
someone who wants to be
in business for themselves
can buy into a brand.
They don't have to discover
the formula all their own.
They can mimic
what has worked before.
There's no better way
to start a partnership
than break bread together.
Let's break some waffles.
It's one thing to have
a big dream,
but these brothers have put in
the hard work that it takes
to make that dream come true.
And I get to play
fairy godmother,
helping them along the way.
How do you like that one?
Caleb: From the moment
we started this business,
we knew we wanted to try
to make a deal on "Shark Tank."
Bryan: It gives
a couple of brothers like us
the opportunity
to grow our business
into something that is good
for our families,
our team members, and our
franchise partners alike.
All: A new way to waffle!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a way
to keep unwanted visitors
away from your property.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Joe Balistreri.
I'm from Shohola, Pennsylvania,
and I'm here seeking $115,000
for 15% equity in my company.
Sharks, property owners
can never feel too secure.
You never know
who's gonna hop your fence,
break onto your property
in the middle of the night,
and rummage through your things.
These bandits cause thousands
of dollars in damages a day.
You know who I'm talking about.
Raccoons.
[ Laughter ]
Working in the pest‐control
industry for the last 15 years,
I've seen it all.
These little bandits
dig through our trash cans,
break into our attics to breed,
and defecate in our pools.
Ohh!
Getting rid of raccoons
can be costly,
and, of course,
there's no guarantee
more won't move in
to take their place.
So that's why I invented
the Critter Pricker...
[ Laughter ]
...the most humane way
to protect your property
against raccoons
and other pesky wildlife.
Being that raccoons
have hypersensitive hands
and a lack of depth perception,
once they come in contact
with the Critter Pricker's
patented plastic strips,
they quickly move on.
Ohh.
Goodbye, trash panda.
Hello, peace of mind.
[ Laughter ]
These strong, polypropylene
plastic strips
snap together very easily,
either end‐to‐end
or side‐to‐side
to customize those locations
you want to protect.
Also, our live hinges allow you
to bend and shape the product
around
square and circle locations,
such as bird feeders
and fences.
The Critter Pricker won't
just keep your property
free of raccoons,
but of unwanted cats
and even humans.
So, who wants to get their paws
on the Critter Pricker
and see how it works?
I got some samples for you.
‐Absolutely.
‐Oh, my gosh. So funny.
That's great.
It's a serious problem.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Oh,
these things are heavy.
Thank you.
Whoa!
Careful.
O'Leary: Thank you very much.
Appreciate it. Thanks.
Oh, wow. These are really
serious prickers.
Oh, my God.
That's for real.
I'm just gonna say,
these are extremely pointy
all up and down,
and if you just touch it,
it's serious.
Ow!
It hurts. Yeah.
So, let's say
a raccoon steps on this.
I mean, this is sharp.
Does it make them bleed?
So, what happens with raccoons,
they have hypersensitive hands.
They can see far,
but not up close,
so they taste,
they feel with their hands.
And when they come into
those areas, like a pool,
they'll have to touch it.
It becomes so uncomfortable.
They're not gonna keep
walking past it,
because
they're only doing this.
Why don't you break down
the numbers for me?
I'm selling them for $27.99
to $32.99 online.
Costs me $8 to make.
So far this year,
I've made $80,000.
So you've made $80,000
in sales? That's it?
This year.
Now, I ran out six weeks ago
because I went to a trade show
in Orlando, and I had
over 800 different pool
technicians say they love it.
So what'd they do?
They bought it.
They bought me out within
two weeks after that trade show.
Pretend you're surrounding
this rug you're standing on
with your product.
How much would that cost me
to surround the edge?
I'm gonna give you
a little better explanation
on how this installs.
As long as you give me
the answer, I'm okay with that.
So, what happens is,
raccoons like only to defecate
on the front step
of the pool.
It mimics them
walking into a shoreline.
It's a latrine. They like
to hide their droppings.
They don't like to do
their droppings where they live.
So you just have to cover
the step?
Front step only.
You're only putting it
around the front step.
But then what happens
when the kids
want to go down the steps
the next morning?
So, what happens is,
the product can be moved.
It's heavy. It won't blow away,
but what happens ‐‐
You set it up every night?
A lot of my customers
just leave it.
But it has to be put
somewhere
where somebody
isn't going to step on it.
Right.
How do you get this
on top of your garbage can?
Don't put it on it. You put it
around the garbage can.
But how does it bend?
I'm missing something.
Can you show us
with one piece?
Sure. This is
three connected strips.
You would build them out
to here.
Oh, at the base.
And so you put one here,
one here, one here.
How wide
does it have to be?
I built it
to be 18 inches.
But that will stop, like,
a big mama raccoon?
She won't jump over?
Yeah, 'cause if you see,
this one's about 24 inches
standing on its feet.
Pull her out of the garbage.
Let's have a look at her.
I don't think
raccoons really jump.
O'Leary: That's a big one.
Cuban: Stuffed it.
But don't they kind of crawl
and walk slowly?
Roadkill.
I mean, I have never seen
a raccoon
that would jump 18 inches,
or...
[ Laughs ]
No, me either.
You haven't seen show raccoons?
Man, there's all kinds.
You know, when I was filming,
I was studying the product.
Now, if you look online,
you're gonna see
all these gimmicky products
say, "Oh, it works."
I wanted to be different.
I wanted to show you results.
You know what, Joe?
I can tell you a couple things.
One, it's obvious
you know your stuff, right?
And not only is it obvious,
you're confident about it.
You're even a little bit
arrogant because you know ‐‐
And that's not a bad thing.
Well, it's education, yeah.
Yeah,
'cause you know, right?
And you're confident
in your knowledge.
But the thing about it is,
I would be terrified
that somebody would set me up
and let, you know,
a neighbor walk on it,
cut their foot or whatever.
But where
are you installing it?
I mean, really, the only way
you're stepping on it
is if it's around the pool.
Yeah, but you're dependent
on your customer...
being smart, right?
Yeah.
And they're not gonna
sue you.
They're gonna sue me, right?
That's the problem for me.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you for your time.
You know,
I think it's a clever solution,
outside‐the‐box thinking.
My concern
is a liability issue.
I could picture
my very nice neighbor
hopping across my fence
and ripping his feet out.
So I think
that really scares me.
Could I ask you
what could scare you even more?
Yeah.
Raccoon roundworm
is in a lot of the droppings,
but when it's defecated
in a pool and it spreads...
Ew.
...'cause your filter turns on,
it literally just spread it.
So you're not using your pool.
I just don't see this working.
I'm out.
Thank you.
An investor has to relate
to the problem.
I've never really had this
problem, but another thing is,
you know, my dogs will be
running around the yard.
I'm gonna forget
that this is out,
and it's gonna cause
a lot more damage there.
Plus, I think that raccoons
are very smart.
I'm gonna have drinks
with a raccoon later on tonight.
I need some advice
on some stuff.
[ Laughter ]
So, the liability,
of course,
for the animals
and for other kids ‐‐
it's just a little dangerous
for me, so I'm out.
Thank you.
I know ‐‐ huge problem.
I know
that it's a solution
that doesn't have poisons
or killing the animal,
which I like.
But everybody here's saying
that they're worried about
either their own pets
or a neighbor or a family member
stepping on it.
Maybe there's something
halfway in between.
You're paying me
to get rid of your problem.
I don't want to waste time,
come to your house 15 times,
getting rid of something
that should have been done
the first time.
I guess I'm just
not bought in 100%,
but I think
you're onto a good idea.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you.
♪♪
John:
Are you interested, Kev?
You have anything else in
your portfolio for pest control?
I don't have a Critter Pricker
in my portfolio.
And that fits you
so well.
[ Laughs ]
Okay.
I'll make you an offer.
I know the product
has merit, okay?
I'm just trying to
figure out how to structure
a deal that makes sense,
'cause you're telling me I got
to pay over a $700,000 valuation
on something
with $80,000 in sales.
I'll give you the $115,000
for the 15%,
so I'm not taking
any more equity,
but I want to get a royalty
of $2.50 a unit.
♪♪
How long, Kev?
It's perpetual.
It's a perpetual royalty.
That keeps me incentivized
to grow the business.
♪♪
You got a deal.
[ Claps hands ]
Thank you, Joe.
Greiner: Congrats, Joe.
Let's go make some money,
my friend.
Cuban: Congrats, Joe, man.
I think it's terrific.
Great idea.
‐Thank you, guys, for your time.
Well done, Joe.
Well done.
Balistreri: I've worked so hard
to get to this point,
and I let it all go,
and it feels good.
And I thank every doubter
who gave up on me,
and I proved them wrong.
I did it.
♪♪
My name is Katey Jo Evans, and
I'm from Bridgeville, Delaware.
I had always dreamed of more
growing up.
I had big dreams
of making my hometown proud
somehow, someway.
When I was in high school,
I saw an ad in the newspaper
for Miss Delaware
National Teen Pageant,
and I really saw that
as my opportunity
to earn some scholarship money,
get a higher education,
and I ended up taking the crown.
I got into
my first‐choice college,
the University of Delaware,
but one summer, I went back home
and met my husband.
So I hung up my crown
for overalls.
Big one.
My husband's
a third‐generation farmer,
and I knew
that he loved it so much,
and I wanted to be
a part of that.
Yeah, this one here
has got a mark.
Yeah.
The more acres and varieties
of produce we grew,
the more we realized that
we were having food go to waste
just because
of cosmetic reasons.
In the U. S. alone,
there are billions of pounds
of wasted produce each year.
For us, times were hard,
and so reducing food waste
was an essential part
of the success of our business.
For us, it's really personal.
When you live and work
on a farm,
there's really no separation
of work and life.
It's what keeps us going.
We get out of bed in the morning
with a passion and a purpose.
It's the legacy
of our whole family.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks!
[ Chuckles ]
My name is Katey Jo Evans,
and I'm a former beauty queen
from Bridgeville, Delaware.
And I'm here
seeking a $125,000 investment
for a 20% equity stake
in my business.
My family's been farming
for more than 75 years.
What?
You guys didn't think
I was a farmer?
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Well, I'm here to tell you
things aren't always
as they look.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Okay.
Take this strawberry ‐‐
misshapen, bruised,
and slightly overripe.
But it's still nutritious
and delicious.
An estimated 1 in 5
fruits and veggies
never leaves the field,
resulting in billions of pounds
of wasted produce each year.
And that's why we started...
The Frozen Farmer.
[ Chuckles ]
We make a full line
of super‐premium ice cream,
dairy‐, gluten‐,
and fat‐free sorbet,
and Nice Cream,
our own part sorbet/
part ice cream blend,
using misfit fruits and veggies
from our own fields.
The Frozen Farmer
is the richest, the creamiest,
the most epic explosion
of farm‐fresh flavor.
So, Sharks, who wants a scoop
of this cool business,
where we turn imperfect produce
into profits?
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
Cuban: I like it.
O'Leary: We gonna try these?
Are these our samples?
These are your samples.
Mmm! Really good.
I think
I just had honeydew.
Wow. It tastes just like
a honeydew melon ‐‐ exactly.
That's because that's really all
that's inside the container.
Wow.
It's fresh fruit,
a little bit of sugar
maybe added.
Very good.
That's all that's in there.
So, really low sugar content?
Can we see your packaging?
Absolutely.
John: Man. It's good.
Oh, wow! The orange creamsicle
was really good.
Yeah, and there's
only 50 calories per serving
in the honeydew.
200 calories
in the whole container?
In the sorbet.
O'Leary: Pretty good.
It's really good.
Wow.
Yeah.
This stuff is good.
Katey Jo, where do you
sell this? How do you sell it?
So, we sell our products
in 70 grocery chain stores.
Giant Foods
is our major grocery buyer.
My husband and I own
a third‐generation family farm,
and we supply Giant
with our produce.
How long has this part
of the business been operable?
So, we established
The Frozen Farmer in 2015.
We went
to Ice Cream University.
We've got the "coolest" degree
in the world.
There's a university?
Where's that? [ Laughs ]
It's in New Jersey.
Of course.
So, we learned
the art of making ice cream.
You can tell, because
these are really fantastic.
Fantastic. Thank you.
Artisanal.
So, in 2019, we've already done
$310,000 in sales.
Our current container average
across the board is $1.75.
So, that's what it costs you
to make?
Correct.
That's high.
And what do you
sell it for?
We wholesale for $3.30.
And they retail for $4.49
to $5.99 on the shelf.
So, what percentage
of your sales
are through
the grocery channel?
So, only 15% of our sales
are actually grocery sales.
We did $46,000 in grocery sales
this year.
The rest of our sales
have been wholesale and on‐farm.
So, you're not using,
like, a commercial kitchen.
We do hand‐pack and hand‐produce
everything in‐house.
And that's why
I'm here today ‐‐
because we can't keep up
at this pace.
Right now, we have
so many grocery customers
knocking at the door.
So, you said
that you were a pageant queen?
I was Miss Delaware
National Teenager in 2005.
The pageant world to farming
couldn't have been
starkly different than I ever
would have imagined it.
You didn't grow up
on a farm?
I did not grow up
on a farm.
So, I actually married
into farming.
I am from a small town,
and, um...
[ Voice breaking ]
I'm sorry.
♪♪
My husband's father
was so much more
to our town than a farmer.
He died in the line of duty
as a volunteer firefighter.
And he left the farm
to my husband.
And so here we were,
two young farmers in our 20s,
and there were
a lot of hard years
that we really worried we were
gonna lose the family farm.
But we just hustled
as hard as we could,
and before we knew it,
we had grown an operation
that used to be 65 acres
and just a dream
to 2,000 acres
is what we till today.
Corcoran: Wow.
What do you want
from a Shark?
I want you to help me take it
to a co‐packer level.
I don't have
the overhead capital right now
to even purchase
the outright container cost
that we're gonna need
to run through the co‐packer.
I also need
some industry expertise.
I'm not gonna lie to you guys ‐‐
I'm a farmer's wife.
I'm a former beauty queen.
I don't know everything there is
to know about the CPG industry,
but I have gotten us
this far.
O'Leary: No, it's impressive.
I have learned and I am learning
every single day.
It is impressive,
Katey Jo.
I think probably
the most underestimated value
in every great entrepreneur
that I've ever worked with
is their ability
to make great judgments.
Because there's two, three,
four, five ways
of doing everything
all along the way.
The concern I have
for what your gift is,
which is enthusiasm
and the great ability to produce
a phenomenal product ‐‐
all of us
couldn't get enough of this ‐‐
that's your gift.
And you can do so well as
a cottage industry doing that,
but I think, to have
the kind of judgment
it's going to take to get this
to be a giant company,
I don't think it's really
what you are going to
necessarily do well.
So for those concerns,
I'm out.
With all due respect, Barbara,
thank you for that, so much.
But I'll be quite honest ‐‐
there's no one else
on the grocery shelf anywhere
doing what we're doing
in being the true
farm‐to‐table operation...
That's not true.
...and the farmer using their
own end product themselves ‐‐
Wait, wait. Katey Jo, the
ice cream business is so hard.
You have to convince
all these grocers or retailers
to give you
refrigerated space.
But I really don't.
Our retail space
has been given to us.
Why is that? Is it
'cause you're already
in business with them?
They know the quality
of our produce.
Their customers
are coming in saying,
"I want Evans Farms produce.
It's the best in the world."
But that's local
'cause they know you, Katey Jo.
You get the edge
because it's a great product
and they know the quality
that comes from your farm.
Once you get to Dallas
and New York
and everywhere else,
you don't have
that home‐court advantage.
You've seen my hustle here.
I'm unable
to hustle this product yet.
We're almost
at production capacity on farm.
I've got to get
to a co‐packer level.
John: You know what?
I think you're getting
a lot of demand
because
you're a local hero.
And it is gonna be
very hard to scale.
This is
a super‐tough business.
One of my best friends
builds the refrigeration
for Giant and Key Food,
and he always told me,
"Promise me you will never
get into refrigerated goods."
[ Laughs ]
Because it's hard
to ship these things.
These trucks are
a lot of money,
as you know,
and it's very, very,
very difficult.
I think
you're gonna be okay, though,
on the farm and locally,
doing what you do.
Just be just as energetic
as you always are,
and I wish you luck,
but I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
Yeah, Katey Jo, the problem is,
to Daymond's point,
refrigerated's hard.
Frozen's even worse.
Because there's
even less space available.
Guys, I love hard.
I have no doubt, right?
I was born for hard.
Look, Katey Jo, what you've
accomplished is great.
What I don't think
you have a grasp on
is what it's gonna take
to scale nationally.
I know you want a fight. It's
not a fight I want to fight.
Small‐label ice creams
are the up‐and‐coming marque.
Look at the margins.
They're the only thing...
You're right.
And there's 30 of them.
...that's carrying the ice cream
industry right now.
Big‐box brands ‐‐ the margins
and profits are down.
You know what?
When 10,000 people
are doing the same thing,
I don't want to be
the 10,001st.
Katey Jo, I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you. Congrats.
Katey Jo,
I love the misfit fruit ideas.
These are rejected
by their peers.
It's great.
That strawberry
got kicked off the branch.
[ Laughs ]
I look at it as a very difficult
business to invest in
'cause of its structure.
Mr. Wonderful, you don't like
easy stuff, either.
No, no, no.
You're up for the challenge.
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Katey Jo has
only two more chances for a deal
for her ice cream and sorbet
company, The Frozen Farmer.
It's a family business.
But, I mean, who's gonna
give you better pricing
on the ingredients
than the farmer themselves?
I love the product.
I love your enthusiasm.
I would so much rather
sell this for ‐‐
But I can't invest
in every business,
and ice cream is just not
the place I want to be.
I wish you the best.
I'm out.
Thank you.
[ Voice breaking ] Lori.
You know, I'm not
a huge ice cream person,
but I have to tell you,
these ice creams were the best
I've ever had in my entire life.
The orange creamsicle,
I thought was one of
the creamiest‐tasting,
best‐tasting things ever.
The sorbets are phenomenal.
So I think that your product
is fantastic.
I think
with the right packaging ‐‐
you really need
your packaging to pop.
I mean, even being called
misfit fruit sorbet
is kind of interesting,
because people who care
about the environment
and not wasting
and using everything
would get that message almost
immediately from that name.
It's a great name.
But it's really, really,
really hard
to be in the ice cream business,
as they all were saying.
But yet you have something that
I think is like Blue Ribbon.
I'm just not sure ‐‐
Come on, Lori.
One, I will help you
redo your packaging,
alright,
no matter what,
so that you will have
a great label,
and I'll help you with the name
and the trademark and that.
Okay.
I'm gonna offer you
the $125,000...
♪♪
...30%.
But I will give you
the money
if we can land
a major national chain
with the product.
Well, it's good
you said that,
'cause I've already had talks
with Harris Teeter and Wegmans.
$125,000 for 30%?
I wouldn't think about it
too long, Katey Jo.
Yes. Like a Wegmans ‐‐
Lori, I will do that deal
with you!
I'm sorry! I know
I'm supposed to negotiate!
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry!
Aaah!
Oh, my!
[ Laughs ]
Congratulations, Katey Jo.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you all for your time.
O'Leary:
Thank you very much.
This has been truly an honor.
Oh, it's heavy!
To wear the crown
is a huge responsibility.
Getting this deal today means
everything to our business.
I mean, who would have ever
thought in a million years
that a farmer's wife
from Bridgeville, Delaware,
would end up on "Shark Tank"
and getting a deal with Lori?
And I'm just
so incredibly grateful.
♪♪